plants vs. zombies garden warfare 2
doubles down on the established pvz
formula by maintaining its cheesy humor
and silly costumes while adding new
characters updated modes and additional
solo content plus a host of smaller
improvements throughout most of its new
material particularly the extra
characters enhance the already enjoyable
core experience though the glacially
paste progression and repetitive
single-player component dampen the fun
the most noticeable difference for
returning players is structural the
entire game now revolves around a
playable hub area with plants on one
side zombies on the other and a
contested area in between there's also a
decent amount of space around the edges
littered with items to collect and
secrets to uncover including a few
minigames that can easily devour more
time than you intended the hub area is
not only loaded with plenty of pleasant
diversions that also provide some
context that allows the rest of the
experience to feel a bit more meaningful
both sides have distinct personalities
and while their oddball rivalry may be
thin it's enough to make the action make
sense it's also an excuse to bombard
players with funds and dad jokes and how
could you not love that beyond its
narrative function the hub world
contains portals to all the various
modes including the cooperative garden
ops horde mode the revamped online
multiplayer component and the brand-new
single-player campaign unfortunately
campaign might be too generous of
description most missions send you on a
fetch quest in the hub world or throw
you into a garden ops match still if you
manage to grind through to the end of
either team story you unlock a blood
dragon a surprise that's pretty
worthwhile
while the single-player content is a bit
of a bust the new characters are
anything but the plants and zombies
received three new characters apiece
bringing the games total to 14 an
impressive number when you consider just
how diverse they all are both visually
and mechanically every character
operates in a totally different way with
different movement speeds primary
weapons levels of Health special
abilities and more and crazier still
there are a hundred and ten mechanically
distinct variants total each base
character also embodies a specific
archetype like tank or sniper so the
newcomers help better balance both teams
every character seems to have a counter
character if you're getting dominated by
someone there's generally a combatant
you can swap - in order to gain the
upper-hand matchups and strategy proofs
central to the experience but this is
where progression pacing becomes a
problem characters level individually so
gaining experience and earning unlocks
with one variant doesn't impact the
others this would be fine except
leveling takes forever to pay off you
can boost one character to level five by
playing online for roughly an hour which
gets you just one passive character
upgrade now imagine how long it would
take to grind to level 50 the current
cap with all 110 character variants this
problem also extends to unlocks the only
way to acquire consumables costumes and
new variants is to buy random sticker
packs but currency accrues just as
slowly as XP this severely limits how
frequently you can buy new stuff and
when you do there's no guarantee you'll
get what you're hoping for at its
current pace unlocking all 110 variants
will take hundreds of hours the good
news is anyone who played the original
game can transfer all their characters
over and you can buy sticker packs and
upgrade your characters in between
rounds when playing online which at
least simplifies the process it's also
possible to enjoy garden warfare twos
robust online multiplayer with even
basic low-level characters the
borderline chaotic action emphasizes
team playing and rewards both offensive
and defensive actions I did find myself
missing certain shooter hallmarks like
sprint Crouch and basic melee options
but the shooting still feels tight and
satisfying plus the character's creative
ability sets end up driving most of the
moment-to-moment gameplay which led to
plenty of glorious moments of chomping
bombing and burning well you will find
standard team deathmatch in Call of Duty
style Kill Confirmed modes there's also
a modified version of Battlefield Rush
mode
as well as a novel match type that
forces two teams to fight over a single
randomly spawning bomb the maps also
shine with hazards bottlenecks
verticality and plenty of visual details
overall the strong mix of maps and modes
should be enough to keep the player base
engaged at least long enough for
everyone to earn if you handful of
character variants so a while with more
generous pacing and more worthwhile
single-player content garden warfare 2
would have been a truly outstanding game
but even without those things it's a
robust shooter with an astounding level
of mechanical diversity it's endearing
the ridiculous presentation remains true
to the series roots and further proves
that shooters don't have to be gray and
gritty to offer a rewarding experience
you